all right tyrone
hey how you doing welcome back again
thank you thank you thank you
thank you so so how are things meant for
you i mean it's been all right man but
you know
you know my mom was thinking thinking
about you know thinking about the belly
of the beast
you know i'm saying and i want to
emphasize on that i'm talking about the
universe
you know i mean you know it's a
universal set
it's designed for a person to go through
the suffering pain and suffering
you know somebody told me that pain is
necessary but
suffering is optional but what if you're
a kid
when i was a kid was it optional for me
then
it was not optional you know uh
i went through things
i figured i shouldn't had to go through
things you know uh
they say what don't kill you make you
stronger i don't believe that
you just adjust to it when it comes to
feelings
you know what i'm saying i mean if you
get if you k
if you kill you just kill you physically
now now feelings is totally different
you know i'm saying you have to people
just adjust
you know i have i had a void in my life
and see and when that void came i had to
feel things
to fill that void whether it was drugs
whether it was sex
or whether whatever it was
and having a void in your life in my
life
it was long before i'm 54 years old now
that void was a long time ago and i
still
still haven't found nothing to fill the
void to make me
satisfied i mean is the universe
designed like that
i mean is the universe designed for me
to
experience and grow or it's just
it's always just his experience
do you believe in god
i'm going to say this i know there's
something up there
some somewhere i mean
i on other planets they say it's aliens
on other planets there's people under
the ground
somebody told me i'm an alien we aliens
we're in the third dimension i mean
there's so many aspects
i don't know what to believe yeah i just
after listening to so many of these
talks
i have a hard time believing there's a
god if he's you know if you listen to
latoya's story
her first video it's like how how can
there be a guy
i mean you would say that if well i mean
that's what i mean that's why i have to
say the universe
because things happen i don't think they
say things supposed to happen just the
way it's supposed to happen
i mean so you mean if it supposed to
happen the way it's supposed to happen
that means poster got my lesson i was
supposed to
get beat up i suppose all right was i
when i was a kid it's pretty hard to
believe after
hearing your story you know i mean how
could you believe that the boogeyman is
real the first story
so so all that is necessary for me right
see and when you get in touch with
feeling sometimes sometimes you get
angry
sometimes you get sad you know what i'm
saying i mean feelings are real
but do do do the universe understand
that
i mean do do do feelings make the
universe go around
because everybody got feelings everybody
got bones in their closet everybody got
things that people don't want them to
know
everybody you know what i'm saying i
mean one cat he told me i ain't got a
problem in the world
you know he got all this money yeah you
filling that void with that money
everybody had i believe i believe
everybody got a void in their life
but they just substitute with something
yeah some
some some better off than others some
stronger than that y'all do it
differently
everybody do is different so so is it
designed
for me i can't say about nobody else was
it designed for me
to go through what i had to go through i
mean i grew physically
yeah but when i hear certain songs
i see certain things i get angry
or i want to shed a tear
i mean the universe
wow what i mean is it spiritually
you know what i'm saying or is the
universe is just
when it's time for me to go is it
afterlife
i mean oh yeah and then somebody said i
mean if
if your life is full of sin you're gonna
die and you're gonna come back again
is that true
i mean there's so many different aspects
that
that's in this universe where people say
i like one person told me i was an alien
i like that
you know what i'm saying i really do i
mean because you got other planets okay
why were they aliens you got they said
they people living under under the
ground
you know what i'm saying so it's like
they said it's like we the third
dimension
so yeah i'm an alien i enjoy that
because it makes me feel like i'm
different
i mean i got to say i got i got to do
something to help try to help me
escape mentally i have to escape
mentally i really do
from this i'm in downtown skid row okay
i have to i can't stay down here
mentally and physically
i'll go crazy so
since i'm down here physically sometimes
i got to escape mentally
and whatever i do to do that whether
it's drugs
you know whether it's uh uh uh doing
whatever
you know i have to i have to leave
sometime
you know because i have disabilities i
can't walk too far i can't get around
too much
so i can't go around other individuals
because they might look at me crazy you
know i walk past
an individual somebody was my own race
and i felt real bad because she locked
the door for her and got closer to a car
and she designed was she raised like
that in this universe
did her parents or whatever because
because i'm homeless
i wasn't even in the car yet and she
looked up
clicked and it made me angry and i
wanted to curse her out
because i wasn't even thinking about her
and that gets me up it gets me upset
when people have aspects
certain things of me that i don't think
about
you know i'm saying i'm not thinking
about you
i don't care about you lady you ain't
helping me you ain't doing nothing for
me
you know what i'm thinking about you for
you ain't making me you ain't breaking
me
you know what i'm saying but you're
gonna lock the door because i'm homeless
and you black i'm black so how's that i
had other individual
different races helped me better my own
people helped me in this universe
but everybody's supposed to be together
you know what i'm saying
we all supposed to be one
but people don't think like that you
know what i'm saying i appreciate you
too mark
you know what i'm saying i really do man
for helping me out you know feed me you
get it
you haven't put clothes on but
everything man and i appreciate you sir
i really do because i know you ain't got
to do none of this
for nobody not even me i'm happy to help
you out you know what i'm saying and
and this universe is so twisted man you
know what i'm saying i understand it
it ain't got to be the way i want it to
be but it could be better
for me i'm talking about me man i ain't
talking about nobody else
because it begins with me and it ends
with me
in this universe because without me it
ain't nobody else i can't do nothing for
nobody
if anything about me folks i got to be
first
i got to do i have to do something
myself while doing
anybody else but i had to go through
this pain
and stuff so
so how can i help somebody if i go
through pain and suffering can i i can
tell somebody my story
i appreciate you on that
but my pain my story
i grew physically but i hear certain
things i
it hurts it hurts man
you know i don't want to deal with no
feelings that's why i medicate myself
i stuff that stuff man stuff and stuff
and stuff and stuff it
cuz i want to deal with pain i don't
want to deal with suffering i don't want
to deal with that stuff
why should i want to deal with that on a
daily basis
why tell me why i mean nobody can't tell
me why
man and tomorrow gonna come with you
without you anywhere go
you feel like life's unfair life feels
unfair
like because them always it's just
it's just what you got dealt certainly
what happened to you
not anything a young man should go
through
i don't believe man a person have to go
through what he had to go through
anybody
but everybody went through something
some just went through different things
man
some had better support than others
that's all
some people just like i say dealt with
things better than other people dealt
with because they
they had other things if i had maybe if
i had money
i wouldn't be tripping but i still would
be
doing what i'm probably doing but in a
different phase
i'd probably be traveling around the
world not dealing with pain
because i had money
everybody do things different man
you know nobody can't tell me they had a
perfect
life nobody can't tell me that nobody
because if you tell me you had a perfect
like you lying
nobody had a perfect life really brother
what what a
daddy beat you or mama beat you or you
the dog
bout you or whatever
everybody got something in their life
that they stuffed
that they don't they might some people
don't bring it up but mine comes up
because i hear certain songs i see
certain things
and anger come
or sadness come
and i don't like dealing with that
man i would do anything for any
individual man i would give you the
shirt off my back
but i feel if i if i feel like you try
to use me
or you try to play me
i don't like that man because i got used
and played when i was a kid
so you go hey go allow nobody to use and
play me now
i'm only going to let you do what i
allow you to do right now because i'm a
grown man but that don't mean i ain't
dealing with no feelings
on a daily basis
you only can do what i allow you to do
you know what i'm saying but when you
when when you're in the belly of the
beast
as they call the universe when you're a
kid you ain't got no choice
because i can't do nothing i can't do
nothing i couldn't say grandma
so i had to help how could he say
and i wish that man was here today
i wish i knew that bed today because
they
because i bet you i could save for the
day
i bet you that much bet you that much
i know that for a fact he wouldn't put
his hand on her
because i wouldn't allowed him to
i might have been in life for the
penitentiary for life
but he wouldn't he wouldn't put his hand
on her
i bet you that much how are you
on me i know that for a fact
but you know this universe man
life feels unfair and i believe that you
know what i'm saying
because life ain't what people say life
is you know
it's just not man you know uh
the universe just things just happen
because it's supposed to happen they say
i don't believe that
it's supposed to happen so
if i hit the lottery do i supposed to
hit the live
if i go out there and leave and get hit
by al qaeda i supposed to get hit by a
car
i see one lady get dragged down the
street did she supposed to get dragged
down the street because the man was
looking down didn't see her
that's what she's supposed to do it
won't be like that she's supposed to get
dragged down the street huh
so if i see that oh well she's supposed
to get mad around feet you know
so the universe is designed like that
you tell me
you know i'm saying then like i say
down here man you got to laugh to keep
from crying sometimes
you have to you know what i'm saying
as we step our feeling as i stuff my
feelings i can't talk about him as i
stuff my feelings while i'm down here
you know what i'm saying i have my
little hey
hey but that don't mean i ain't hurting
you know what i'm saying i listen to
certain music sometimes they escape
while i do what i do
you know what i'm saying i get by myself
and listen my this is just meals and
people be looking at me like
because that's that way i get a piece of
mind some type of way
doing what i do and the music i escape
mentally you know i'm saying some people
don't know how to do that
that's why a lot of people out here go
crazy
because they stayed out here mentally
and physically
mentally and physically i just stayed
out here physically
and only that's the only reason i keep
going
you know and maybe later on down the
line maybe i'll
fill my void with something else i don't
know you know
but right now it's working for me at
this very moment
you know at this very moment it works
for me really
i deal with tomorrow when tomorrow come
i deal with the next 10 minutes when the
texas a minute is gone
because the next 10 minutes i might take
a step
and that's where it's supposed to be i
guess so
you know i mean
i get so angry sometimes at the universe
or at whatever they say it is whatever
it's supposed to be
whatever people believe
whatever works for you works for you i
understand that
but i get angry because
it shouldn't it this thing should have
been different man
you know what i still i still get upset
because i had a dog named duke
and he ran away from home or somebody
stole them i don't know
i still think about that dog when i was
a kid
that dog was i was a kid that's what
that's what i wanted when i used
that that's why i became friend with
princess i got it
my auntie i was too young to go with my
cousins and them
they didn't want to babysit me so i had
to stay home with the old folks
as they drinking and dancing doing all
that thing and they told me you know
what i'm saying go outside
my only friend was princess that was the
dog me and the dog look out
how'd you sneak and drink the beers on
the table they used to leave on the
table
only friend i had when i was a kid was
just the whole princess
i remember that there's a lot of things
i remember man
there's a lot of things i don't want to
remember but i remember
because i hear certain things i see
certain things i can't help but remember
man
it's gonna come up
it's gonna come up man feelings
feelings man the belly of the beast is
designed
i guess it's designed for me to feel
when i was five six seven years old they
said you're feeling stopped then
because i stopped going through some
things so i know how to deal with my
feelings then so
as i grew and got older
physically my feelings stayed at five
six seven years old
is that why i i shed a tear so easy
cause a kid shed a tear so easy
because they can't deal with feelings or
i can't deal with feelings
is that it that's what they say
or do i don't want to deal with feelings
because when i was a kid he used to
steal the beards off the table
it worked for me and it kept working for
me
so i just i guess i just as time went by
i just advanced to different things
to deal with them feelings so is my
feeling still five six seven eight years
old
or did i just know how to adjust to my
feelings
and keep going
as life or the universe got me doing
keep going
because it's the way it's designed so it
was designed for me to
do what i did steal the beers
it was designed for me to hang out with
princess
the dog he was designed for that huh
so everything i it was designed for and
i went through
i guess i supposed to go through huh
i guess i'm supposed to go through what
i'm going through right now
cause it's designed like that they say
they tell me that as i'm a kid they tell
me this they tell me so many things
and i grow up and i'm supposed to
believe so many things
and then when i get to be um uh four
years over half a century
now i believe my own aspect of things am
i right or am i wrong
because i have my own belief system
because i get tired of things sometimes
i can tell you
steering me wrong so i might as well
step myself wrong
if anything
because the universes
got me going left and i guess i was
supposed to win right but i guess the
universe said i supposed to went left
man they say life is hard huh
but but it's fair some say it's unfair
some say it's fair
how is it fair because you got an
opportunity no i didn't have
opportunity because my opportunity was
going a long time ago
when i was a kid when my feelings got
stagnated
so i didn't go feelings
wise but i grew physical wise
so so how is it fair
because like i said when i was stealing
them bills off that table
when everybody was in there when the old
people were drinking and playing music
doing everything
that worked for me
so i and they say you know people ask me
man would you do a different future
no i wouldn't did it different because
why should i do it
did it different and it was going to
happen the same way
you didn't say if if it happened to you
different what you did it different you
asked me would i do it different
no because the same thing would happen
if the same thing happened to me
why should i do it different person ask
me that
you got to be careful i have to i have
to start learning what individuals say
to me
because you asked me a question you know
i'm saying when anybody asks me a
question i have to think like wait a
minute
because because sometimes i think it's
one of them trick questions
now you're trying to trick me what you
trying to do because i don't trust you
anyway
cause it's hard to trust people man
it's hard to trust people i mean you
know what i'm saying
uh they got this song man
i don't say his name man i ain't broke
nothing but he says you know what i'm
saying
i might love somebody but i don't trust
nobody
because they said man we'll let you down
you know what i'm saying
i might love somebody but i don't trust
nobody
you know what i'm saying because because
he talks about his family
he talks about everybody that's close to
him
he don't trust but he loves them
and i can identify with that
i can identify with that you know what
i'm saying but then
it's like i said seven songs i might
hear i can identify with but then
you hear an old song from the old school
and i think about grandma
because that's when i grew up that's the
songs i hear
i heard a lot
and certain things put me in certain
situations man
you know what i'm saying you know
sometimes
i'd be willing to get violent and i'm
not a violent individual
i'm not
for real i mean it's certain people in
store for me
and i see them and a certain song hit my
mind
i'd be wanting to chop their fingers off
cause you stole from me man
i don't steal from you i don't do none
of that
so why you won't go there i don't have
anything and you're gonna take from me
and then you're gonna sleep on the
sidewalk and i will chop your finger and
that's the way my mind thinks
at that very moment
so i have to i have to i have to lay
here and escape
mentally so i won't do nothing crazy
because like i say man if i stayed out
here physically
and mentally i would go nuts
i got to escape man i have to man
i'm conditioned a certain way
four years over half a century that
sounds like a long time
four years over half a century i don't
want to see another half a century
give me my 80s i'm go i'm cool
give me my 80s i'm cool because i don't
want to go out [ __ ] and
shooting ain't no diaper none of that
they come in the diaper you leave out a
diaper i won't be in no diaper
for real i don't want to be in no diaper
no
i still want to move out and see some i
mean man
but i know things ain't gonna go out the
way i wanted to go because it never did
you know what i'm saying if the thing
like if things go the way i wanted to go
it'd be all right but it ain't designed
like that
this universe is not designed for it to
go the way i wanted to go or any way
anybody else wanted to go
it just don't work like that cause like
i said life's gonna go on with you
or without you anywhere i go you know
tomorrow's still gonna come
you know what i'm saying and like i said
man i enjoy it
man i don't mean no disrespect to y'all
hey man i appreciate it mark
man i ain't got no more love for you man
i really do man
okay love for you okay hey man
i appreciate you all man god bless you
man thank y'all man hey
i hope y'all like i say man god people
got different aspects of god
i don't i don't believe in god but
i believe in the universe so the
universe bless you
if god bless you whoever bless you let
him bless you
but the universe blessed me god bless
you i just go with the flow
thank you
you